let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud and do not give a [ __ ]
is that Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [ __ ] eating
[ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
wow happy happy happy hump day
it's four o'clock Eastern three o'clock
Central you know what time that is it's
time for let's talk the Tony Michaels
podcast
there's so much in the news today
I wish I had the ritten house clips for
you
but I will have to describe what's going
on because at the written houses at the
top of the list today even though I have
a [ __ ] list prepared for you guys
because you know we do the [ __ ] list
here
writtenhouse Kyle Rittenhouse that
murderer
on trial taking the stand admits that
he's a liar on the stand
gives a
non-oscar-nominated performance of
trying to conjure up some tears
to gain sympathy
from the jury
haven't we had about enough of this
stuff this Q Anon gqp proud boy pew pew
garbage
somehow he's supposed to be a [ __ ]
superhero for the right wing
and he's crying or trying to cry he
wasn't actually crying he was trying to
cry
couldn't couldn't even well up one
crocodile tear
I wonder how well that's gonna go for
him in life
and the prosecution I just seen a clip
where the prosecution
it gets him to admit on the stand that
he's a liar this is why generally a
defense does not take the stand
it does not normally go well when the
defense takes the stand and normally
it's a last-ditch effort
um most of the time when the defense
actually takes the standards because the
person thinks that they're better off
telling their own story which is a real
dumb idea and a trial like this where
all the evidence points to You're a
murderer
or they think that they don't have a
shot in hell at the verdict that they
want from the jury so it's a it's a it's
a last-ditch Hail Mary
really bone-headed and Kyle
rittenhouse's case
to fake cry and then to admit that he's
a liar on the stand all the while we
have this judge
um the the seeming
seeming to steer this trial it almost
seems like yeah every every time we get
a clip of this this [ __ ] judge
it seems like he's got a lot of Sympathy
For The Proud boy that that is on trial
here because let's face it that's what
happened that's what this is you
remember when he was out on bail and
there was pictures of him at bars
where he was throwing up the three
percenter sign with a bunch of white
supremacists
he did not go there to render people
Medical Aid he went there to pretend
that he was rendering people age so he
could shoot and kill people and that's
what he did
there is other news though
that I want to get to today
um and I I actually did a a majority of
Kyle Rittenhouse commentary on the
stream on Twitch this morning so go go
over to Twitch and find that you can you
should follow us on on Twitch anyways uh
we do the live stream the shitless
Roundup
where we round up the [ __ ] list to do it
here on the podcast to give you the [ __ ]
list every week
and there's a lot on the [ __ ] list and a
lot of it ain't even gonna make it on
the podcast [ __ ] list there's so much
goddamn garbage out there
Jesus [ __ ] Christ
but you should go follow us on Twitch
download the Twitch app it's easy to
actually watch the twip at Twitch app
and surf Twitter all at the same time so
go follow us over there the Tony
Michaels catch us every day over there
at noon Eastern
but let's get back to the uh to to the
to the news at hand we have uh Georgia
is on my mind uh we have uh Karen Rogers
excuse me Aaron Rodgers uh still in the
news today uh and then we had yesterday
we had uh uh Paul gozar uh grocer as I
like the coin now at the [ __ ]
seditionist
uh posted a video on Twitter so we're
gonna get to that uh we are in subpoena
City now we are inside the city limits
of subpoena City and the population is
growing for the January 6 select
committee subpoena list holy [ __ ] I I
wouldn't be surprised if they drop a
bigger list today of more people that
are going to be subpoenaed but there's a
few names in this list that I want to go
through on the [ __ ] list today
and and really break down uh what this
what this means and and make sure we
have a good memory of who these
[ __ ] are
uh and then the last thing I want to
talk about is uh Big Bird porn
as you've heard there's a bunch of
Republican politicians out there elected
officials that are more concerned about
Big Bird and porno
than they are about real issues in this
country they're really upset that Joe
Biden got a win on this infrastructure
bill so they can't help but to attack a
a fictional six-year-old Bird puppet
from Sesame Street and to attack
um porn watching and video game playing
and I don't know it did Josh Hawley is
completely terrified that his
masculinity is being questioned
apparently so we'll get to that as well
on today's [ __ ] list
so one thing I do want to mention while
I'm here is we were supposed to have a
special guest Friday our schedules did
not meet today to record but I'm hoping
we can record before Friday comes so we
can air that uh episode 50 with a
special guest if we do record it and we
do get it recorded and in the can to air
on Friday I will announce on Twitter who
that guest will be so stay tuned on
Twitter uh hopefully we will get that
recorded in the next day or two to get
that aired Friday at the same time same
place YouTube Twitter twitch four
o'clock Eastern three o'clock Central if
we can get that guest episode in the can
we just had some scheduling conflicts
today to make that happen but maybe
we'll do it next week or Friday we'll
we'll get that guest on the show for
um but we're in episode 49. can you
believe that 49 episodes of the podcast
and I appreciate all the people out
there that listen to the podcast
download like share all that kind of
stuff so and then and that that support
is much appreciated and if you guys go
download the podcast in either Google or
Spotify or apple give us a review there
a five star review
or whatever review you want but give us
a review there if you would please
that'll help us out or you can go to the
merch store and get [ __ ] a merch you
just use the promo code podcast 10 off
all those links are are at the Tony
michaels.com so just go to
thetonymichaels.com if you want to
support the podcast that way all the
proceed proceeds from the merch go to
all the cost here at the podcast so we
can keep it going the same way with the
uh the twitch the twitch stream so let's
get into it let's start the [ __ ] list
the shitlist
all right today on the [ __ ] list top of
the mind is Georgia Georgia and Georgia
's on my mind um as you heard maybe
maybe you didn't maybe you did I think
this is a very important news the
Atlanta district attorney uh is
convening a special grand jury in her
criminal investigation of the election
interference from the former guy Grandpa
Poopypants is going to be the subject of
a special grand jury in Georgia
the past the prosecutor Fannie Willis of
Fulton County opened her inquiry in
February so this is a uh grand jury
that's being conveyed convened after the
prosecutor in Fulton County which is a
heavily Democratic County by the way in
the Atlanta District uh is opening up
this grand jury from an inquiry in
February if you go back and remember
what happened in January you guys
remember January 6th right I'm sure you
do
uh you know the the seditious treasonous
violent Insurrection that happened from
the gqp that they encouraged and
apparently members of the gqp Congress
help plan we'll probably talk about that
later on in the show with the gozar and
the Sedition sisters along with subpoena
City
but first off before we got to January
6. if you remember January 6 was on
a Tuesday
and the craziest part is that Sunday
before
there was a bombshell piece of news it
was a audio tape from a phone call that
was made by Grandpa Poopypants and his
shark army to Brad rathisberger the
secretary of state of Georgia
and what Grandpa Poopypants the Cheeto
dust mobster was really twisting the arm
of the Secretary of State who is
the elected official who handles
elections in the state of Georgia was
urging him and it was like this it was
kind of like this
uh you like you like being Secretary of
State boy it sure would be it would be
horrible if something happened to you
being Secretary of State of Georgia
and all you need to do is find me 11 780
votes because that is the exact number I
need
to lie to the American people to make
sure they think I won Georgia which I
didn't
he says [ __ ] you remember the phone call
that's the phone call and that's what
set this inquiry off
into election interference election
fraud
you know they keep saying oh the
election was rigged and rigged and I
mean they they want it to be rigged and
what I mean is they want it to be rigged
in their favor
they always want the election to be
rigged in their favor because they're
[ __ ] fascist
normally a president of the United
States who loses in the state does not
call the state election official who is
in charge of the state elections and
pressure them to find just just under 12
000 votes in a mattress somewhere that
is normally not what happens in a
democracy like ours unless unless you
have someone like Grandpa poopy pants at
the helm
and if you guys read any stories about
the subpoena that was issued and we're
going to get to that here later on in
the [ __ ] list
but I'm telling you there are a few of
these characters that were involved in
planning January 6. and that the January
6 Insurrection and the John Eastman memo
the late the way they laid out the plan
to execute uh uh the where Mike Pence
would overthrow the election by just
declaring Donald Trump King of the
United States that plan in the Eastman
memo that was really one of their last
ditch efforts they tried several times
and it looks like it looks like the
Atlanta district attorney is going to
convene a grand jury and you don't just
convene a grand jury for nothing they
don't just do it because they don't have
evidence
of a crime they're trying to present
what they think is a crime to a grand
jury does he have a grand jury will
convict
indict excuse me
the jury convicts
the court jury I'm not a lawyer
I'm not a lawyer
don't take legal advice from me
but I'll guarantee damn sure to you the
people you don't want to take legal
advice from is anyone tied to Grandpa
Poopypants
that is definitely what you don't want
to do
so let's move on to the next actually um
let me show you one thing uh before we
move on there I do have uh an article
here that a Murder She Wrote a Mueller
she wrote excuse me uh with the article
in the New York Times breaking the
Fulton County D.A Fannie Williams is
about to in Panama grand jury in her
Rico probe because that's what that's
what this is is a RICO probe they call
it small Rico because Rico's a federal
thing but Most states have a RICO like
law where they can prosecute under that
law and they call them small Rico inside
these states that's what's happening
with the case in the Manhattan DA's
office
so now not only is there a grand jury
convened in the state of New York uh and
indicting the Trump organization and its
and some of its officers and apparently
we're gonna maybe see more indictments
out of that grand jury but now we have a
grand jury convened in the state of
Georgia in the Atlanta district for
election interference and election fraud
sedition
hmm kind of funny how that works out and
there's only there's there's one guy in
common with those two grand juries
there's gonna be I have a feeling
there's going to be a lot of grand
juries in this country that are going to
have one person
one one person that is in common with a
lot of grand juries
oh well you know we'll see so let's move
on to our next topic on the [ __ ] list uh
Karen Rogers horseshit
um have you heard this of course you
probably heard Aaron Rodgers uh he's a
lying sack of [ __ ] and uh he lied about
being vaccinated now you try to play it
off on a pot you know and and to the
media saying he was inoculated and then
he had to come out and admit that he was
he was lying he was trying to make it
seem as if he was vaccinated so he
didn't have to follow certain protocols
uh for his being a player and being in
the NFL and for the Green Bay Packers
uh
the the
he took advice from Dr Joe Rogan well
let me tell you something if if people
out there are going to take medical
advice from podcasters let this
podcaster tell you listen to [ __ ]
actual experts and go get [ __ ]
vaccinated it's the right thing to do
just just just stop with the nonsense
stop with the [ __ ] stop with the
division that's not vaccines [ __ ]
work this vaccine works the numbers
prove it out there was a there was
another article out
um this week proving and showing the
data that more and more red counties
Trump counties
have higher rates of infection and death
than quote unquote non-trump counties
that didn't vote for Trump and it has
nothing to do with Trump being elected
or not being elected it just has to do
with this [ __ ] Q Anon cult CRT JFK
Voodoo it's [ __ ] voodoo
it's nonsense absolute complete [ __ ]
Q Anon nonsense
if you if you're if you're considering
not getting vaccinated and you're an
able-bodied person and you you can
receive a vaccine meaning you're not uh
there's no medical condition that's
keeping you from receiving it and you're
a working person and you're around a
bunch of human beings all the time and
you're not taking the vaccine for I
don't care what the reason is I don't
care it does not matter to me anymore at
this point we are almost a year into
this we have plenty of data proving
the opposite of what you're saying if
you are not getting vaccinated you have
some kind of excuse
you are you are now you are now leaking
into the Q Anon Universe of voodoo
that is what this is It's The Cult we
have to quit this cult [ __ ] this cult
[ __ ] is enough we do not need to listen
to The Cult anymore the vaccines work
it's provable the data shows it out and
the data not only shows the vaccinated
people are safer and the communities are
[ __ ] safer with the vaccine but it
shows that people who are unvaccinated
are not as safe and more likely to be in
danger and endangering people inside
those communities so get with the
[ __ ] program here be [ __ ]
patriotic and realize that the mandates
aren't out to hurt you it's to protect
everyone else
so stop with the nonsense you [ __ ]
Karen Rogers
uh Terry Bradshaw really [ __ ] rolled
him up and smoked that [ __ ] this
weekend when he basically called Aaron
Rodgers out and said look you're such a
dumb [ __ ] for taking not only taking the
advice of Joe Rogan but taking a horse
dewormer you're taking a parasecticide
it's it yes there's human Ivermectin but
it's a parasecticide it's a dewormer
stop acting like it isn't all the [ __ ]
you're reading on the internet it's all
[ __ ] all of it it's all been proved
to be complete utter [ __ ] [ __ ] on
Ivermectin even the manufacturer of
ivermectin says it's [ __ ] stop
stop taking advice from [ __ ]
Knuckleheads if the [ __ ] [ __ ] waffles
like [ __ ] Joe Rogan he is not a
doctor he is not an infectious disease
expert he is a [ __ ] chucklehead
and chuckleheads are gonna do what
chuckleheads do
the most disappointing news that we had
today really the thing that really
pisses me off about the Aaron Rodgers
thing the thing that really [ __ ] gets
my goat because it's not surprising that
Aaron Rodgers is an entitled [ __ ]
white dude that is not that's not
surprising I mean Jesus Christ is
predecessor [ __ ] Brett Favre is the
same goddamn way
thinks there's something [ __ ] special
when it comes to [ __ ] infectious
disease we don't give a [ __ ] if you
throw a [ __ ] football when it comes
to infectious disease you're a host for
that disease to get other people
infected it doesn't matter what you do
or how you do it or how well you do it
how many Super Bowl rings You've Won sit
down and shut the [ __ ] up
this is about this is about making sure
that human beings and ever all the
community around you your co-workers the
athletes the doctors the staff
the people who the people who [ __ ]
sweep the floors in the goddamn building
you son of a [ __ ]
it's about keeping all those people safe
that's what the [ __ ] OSHA rule is
about is keeping workplaces sake safe
from infectious disease Aaron Rodgers
you [ __ ] [ __ ] bum
but again the thing that pisses me off
the most I'm gonna get to it here is
that Aaron Rodgers it was announced that
he'll be fined just over fourteen
thousand dollars
and the Green Bay Packers find three
hundred thousand dollars for not
following coveted protocols when they
knew they knew he wasn't vaccinated they
knew it they were lying about it
so not only is that [ __ ] still going to
play football but he only has to give 14
000 just over 14
000 of his own money of his 40 million
dollars or whatever the [ __ ] it is it's
something stupid it's something stupid
this is if this is like
this is ridiculous we we live in a
[ __ ] country
we're an NFL quarterback
can lie about being vaccinated for an
infectious disease
and likely likely making their workplace
less less safe because of it by lying
the team and the workplace lying and
pretending like he is vaccinated when he
was not it was all [ __ ]
and they don't have to be vaccinated in
the NFL they just have to follow certain
protocols if they're not to keep other
people safe
it's really not that [ __ ] complicated
you [ __ ] boneheads
but the most disappointing thing in this
country where a quarterback puts the
lives and health
of the people around him the direct
people around him
from the coaches to the players to the
staff to the people who sweep the floors
in the goddamn Stadium
foreign
just over fourteen thousand dollars when
they make forty million
and yet and yet Colin Kaepernick can't
find a position on the team as a
quarterback because he kneeled during a
song
and people like Aaron Rodgers were
[ __ ] offended
do you see do you see why people are a
little pissed off
do you see people aren't pissed off
because Aaron Rodgers is a [ __ ]
bonehead of course Aaron Rodgers is a
[ __ ] bonehead and entitled little
crybaby bonehead [ __ ] him [ __ ] him
I say cut him loose [ __ ] him expel him
take him out of the league sit his ass
at home let him watch football [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him
Terry Bradshaw was almost as upset as I
am about it
but I think it's a little ridiculous
that the NFL decides that fourteen
thousand dollars is the appropriate fine
for keeping keep putting putting other
people's Health in danger
and making the workplace unsafe
intentionally so it wasn't unintentional
they knew he wasn't vaccinated they knew
they weren't following proper protocols
here
[ __ ] [ __ ] boxes
speaking speaking of [ __ ] [ __ ] boxes
oh baby do we have plenty of [ __ ] boxes
to go around this week oh man we got we
got the former guy down in Georgia we
got Kyle Rittenhouse that [ __ ]
murderer we got Karen Rogers up in Green
Bay and boy let me get the Paul gozar
because we got some other [ __ ] boxes
that we're gonna get to on the list but
Paul goes are is next
um you've probably seen uh this uh this
tweet here now this tweet here is from
his personal account and Dr Paul gozar
which Twitter should make him change
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] handle
but he says he says in this tweet the
creativity of my team is off the hook
now if you are aware of what happened
this week with Paul guzar
um on his official con Congressional
account so he's got two accounts right
there's two Twitter accounts there's his
personal account which is this one here
you see on the screen and then he has
his Congressional account like his
official Congressman account where he is
officially a congressperson on that
Twitter handle
they posted a video that was some and I
I'm not I'm not really up to speed on
anime but it was an anime video that had
uh other uh politicians faces pasted on
the characters and at one point in the
video and you can go watch the video I'm
not gonna play it here because [ __ ] this
guy but you can go find it it's on the
Internet it's there yeah even though you
see here in the tweet that the tweet
that he's quote tweeting here which is
the Tweet with the video
from his official Congressional account
they deleted it there was so much heat
that they deleted it from their their
official Congressional account Paul's
gozar
but the video shows
um Paul goes art uh apparently looks
what seems to be he's cutting off the
head of AOC and he's possibly cutting
off the head of President Joe Biden in
the video
and I think this was all intentional
when they posted on the Congressional
account and the reason why I think it
was intentional is this
here's why Twitter did not take it down
immediately off
the Congressional account they put up a
a warning basically saying hey this
breaks our terms of service but we're
leaving it up because it's a public
interest because it's on a on a
congressman's account I believe Paul
goes are did this intentionally and I
believe his tweet here from his personal
account is intentional to throw his team
under the bus
it's obvious here that he he blames it
on his team that he didn't do this you
know this is in typical gqp proud boy
seditionist treasonous [ __ ] style here
he's [ __ ] seditious insurrectionist
like Paul goes are these white
supremacists hanging around Nick Fuentes
and cheering on Kyle Rittenhouse that
[ __ ] murderer
same same [ __ ] group of [ __ ]
and it's a big sack of [ __ ] that we
got to go around
but he clearly blames it on his team
uh in this tweet and this was all
intentional now again they've tweeted or
they've deleted the original tweet as
you can see here from the Congressional
account
but the evidence is still the same it
doesn't change the fact that it happened
it doesn't change the fact of of of how
it was pres presented on the official
Congressional account and shame on
Twitter
for saying it broke the terms of service
this is what they did with [ __ ]
Grandpa Poopypants this is what they did
with him oh he broke the cert terms of
service but but
they get special treatment because it's
a public interest [ __ ] you
so breaking the terms of service is
public interest publish a story about it
Twitter
don't keep the post up
of Paul gozar projecting that he wants
to cut the head off other politicians in
particular AOC and Joe Biden
especially after we know now that he
tried to plan a violent Insurrection
that killed police officers and other
people during the January 6 violent
insurrection
which they want to rewrite history and
wash whitewash it as if it's some kind
of tour and it was it was it was a
gathering of supporters who were showing
political support it was political
violence and aimed to overthrow the
Constitution of the United States you
seditious [ __ ]
hopefully we can get back
to the January 6th Select Committee
issuing more subpoenas and getting to
the bottom of this
we need to hear soon from mayor Garland
in the doj what the hell their plan is
about Steve Bannon and all the upcoming
other criminal contempt charges that are
going to be referred to them is there a
grand jury is there is there a grand
jury convened is that what we're waiting
on is we're waiting on the grand jury to
see the evidence and if they're if they
are seeing the evidence is there that
much [ __ ] evidence that this is
Criminal contempt because we just seen
we just seen
then it just announced that another
judge has told Donald Trump to go [ __ ]
himself for his executive privilege case
in in the Steve Bannon information
because let's be clear here uh Grandpa
Poopypants is is trying to stop
information to be uh uh uh given to the
select committee because he thinks he
has executive privilege which he does
not
um and I wish I had the quote from the
judge here
I don't have it handy but she basically
says you're not the [ __ ] president
it's not you're not you're not the
president the office holds the privilege
not a person you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and anyone who understands how the
office of the presidency Works which
they didn't and we're going to get to
that here in the next subject with
subpoena City
they did not understand they didn't get
it they don't get it they're not gonna
get it they're not gonna get it they're
not gonna figure out what the office of
the presidency means and how it's our
office it's We the People we're the
government we elect you and we unelect
you you stupid [ __ ]
because there was more news there was
more news as they were laying Siege to
the Capitol because gozar green bobert
Madison cawthorne Biggs Mo Brooks you
[ __ ] they all were helping plan this
seditious treasonous violent
Insurrection to overthrow the
Constitution the United States all the
while
vice president Mike Pence was held up in
a parking garage couldn't get in with
their badges their security badges their
access badges were turned off
couldn't get back in the building
couldn't move around they were trapped
in a parking garage
all the while there was Gallows outside
the capitol
and the violent mob was chanting hang
Mike Pence
in a weird way in a weird way Mike Pence
is still kissing the Cheeto dust ass
of his mango Mussolini Jesus
oh
I just don't understand the stupidity
the Q Anon cult-like Voodoo that we have
this JFK Junior CRT Voodoo just [ __ ]
absolute 100 lies in Voodoo that these
people are Believing on these Facebook
Ivermectin groups like Aaron Rodger
calls Joe Rogan at the Dr Joe Rogan
Ivermectin Institute to get his [ __ ]
medical advice what the [ __ ] has
happened to our education system in this
country
did it all of a sudden fall apart
Jesus so let's get on to the next
subject subpoena City subpoena City uh
you guys have heard uh the list is
growing and growing and growing uh these
subpoenas that are happening from the
January 6th select committee uh on
November 8th so that would have been
Monday
um we had names like Jason Miller you
chinless bastard uh John Eastman the
architect of the Cheeto dust kangaroo
coup the architect that was the thing
that was the blueprint that they used
that's what they wanted to use
was Eastman's memo encouraged by Mike
Flynn
and Sydney Powell Lynn wood
and apparently others inside the
administration
apparently others inside the
administration and yesterday late
yesterday we got a new list
we have a new list
of subpoenas that have been issued
names like Stephen Miller
you know gerbils
at Nazi [ __ ] and Kaylee mcenany
lying Barbie
but there is one other name that is in
particular and an article that was
released but I definitely want to get to
but let's take a quick break and we'll
talk about that on the other side
to sit your ass down
[Music]
we're not finished
[Applause]
foreign
Joe Biden delivers a 1.2 trillion dollar
American infrastructure bill that pays
for roads Bridges and high-speed [ __ ]
internet thanks for Brandon
[Music]
the Tony Michaels podcast Wednesdays at
4 pm Eastern 3 P.M Central watch live on
YouTube on Twitter and twitch download
on Apple and Spotify now here's Tony
[Music]
thanks for staying with us through the
break
and you guys like that uh little
headline
they're really pissed off about
infrastructure aren't they I mean they
are [ __ ] pissed they are pissed and
we're gonna go through that in our last
subject here today but that I want to
get back to this subpoena City and I
want to get back to these these
seditious [ __ ] uh inside this the
inside the administration that the the
story is starting to piece the puzzles
together
the pieces of the puzzle are coming
together with these subpoenas what I
mean by that we're seeing we're seeing
who was involved in this but there was
an article
um that was released about one of the uh
subpoenas
a little known character inside the
Trump orbit because this person was not
out in front of a microphone there was a
story back when John Kelly was uh the
the chief of staff were he actually
fired this individual because they
couldn't pass a federal background check
because they had dumped a bunch of money
or something with gambling and bank
accounts they couldn't pass the mustard
this the smell test
for a background check for a federal
background check to work inside the
administration
and John Kelly [ __ ] canned his ass
now
the craziest part is when John Kelly was
gone this person was hired back into the
administration and how they were hired
back into the administration
is the president of the United States
whoever that is has the right to
override any kind of security clearance
here is the article this is a tweet from
Rick Wilson
um it says uh uh batshit Bonkers piece
on the reign of Johnny mcatee
and basically this article lays out that
Johnny mcentee who is a former
quarterback of the of Uconn apparently
um but he's been with Trump ever since
the very beginning ever since the guy
basically come down the golden escalator
and called Mexican Mexicans rapist and
and murderers almost from that point on
and he literally like he is the coffee
boy like you know every time every time
we have a new character in this Trump
story they
they always they always come out and oh
I didn't know that person I I I I barely
met that person I take pictures with a
lot of people how am I supposed to know
every Rudy Giuliani who's Rudy Giuliani
who's Michael Cohen who could that
possibly be personal attorney I have
lots of personal attorneys I take
pictures with lots of personal attorneys
but here we are here we are it's an
actual coffee boy this was the coffee
boy
in this piece
lays out this piece that I'm talking
about that Rick is uh tweeted here from
the Atlantic
lays out that Johnny mcatee
was the like Deputy president this guy
was in the Euro Grandpa Poopypants and
the reason why Grandpa Poopypants was
listening to him is because Johnny would
say anything that Trump wanted to hear
absolutely anything he wanted to hear
how great he was how thin he was how
good looking he was how great his hair
looked
Diet Coke is is a health drink
Big Macs and and fish fillets or health
food yeah absolutely Mr President yep
sure is
yep
keep at it oh boy you look really thin
today in that suit Mr President that
that tie tied the way that you tie it
all the way down past past your knees
that looks really good Mr President
[Laughter]
but again this person was canned was
[ __ ] canned by John Kelly because he
couldn't pass the mustard
of a federal background check to be
inside the administration
hmm
kind of funny
but then he appears back into the
administration when John Kelly leaves
because Donald Trump needs a Fluff her
right outside the Oval Office anytime
he's feeling down or you know his
Twitter account wasn't doing what he
wanted it to do or
people people were just saying saying
stuff like he was the dumbest president
ever and that's not how president
presidenting works
he called on Johnny to come in and fluff
him
and the dangerous [ __ ] happened during
the pandemic
when they are continuing to to
try to out people in the government that
weren't so keen on what the Trump
Administration was doing and get the
amount of government purge them in other
words you know that that [ __ ] Tucker
Carlson uh stupid [ __ ] propaganda
film that Nazi propaganda film about
January 6th where they call it the
Patriot Purge they were they it's always
projections with these [ __ ]
always they're trying to project people
who were career who were who worked for
career
politicians they were trying to purge
them out of the government because they
weren't exactly keen on how the Trump
Administration was doing and then after
the election it was even worse it got
even worse it got even weirder
with this Johnny
with mcfluffer you know I've been
calling Kevin McCarthy mcflover but
maybe this guy is actually mcfluffer I
don't know
apparently his death sat right outside
the Oval Office he had his own little
special space
so Donald Trump could call on him
whenever he needed
to to have an ego boost as if this guy
needs a [ __ ] ego boost
Jesus Christ
but I think the best part about this
whole story is is that obviously John
mcatee is a [ __ ] bonehead absolute
[ __ ] idiot he does not know how
government works he didn't know how it
works he was way out of his League he he
was not he was not in a position where
he could handle the work that he needed
to do that was being that was needed to
be done for Donald Trump not only to win
the presidency but to run the [ __ ]
government and this is why this is
another reason why Donald Trump always
loses and he's a [ __ ] loser is
because the only people that will
[ __ ] support him are [ __ ] people
that don't know what the [ __ ] they're
doing [ __ ] boneheads are the only
people that stick around with him for a
very certain amount of time most people
leave once they figure out that this guy
is a [ __ ] maniac
Johnny mcentee is a such a [ __ ]
bonehead he doesn't realize that Grandpa
Poopypants has lost his goddamn mind
and I don't know that that's a bad thing
that Johnny mcatee is is Donald Trump's
go-to guy I mean if if if trumpism is
our enemy in this country and we want to
stop fascism
and we want democracy we want to be
pro-democracy we want to make sure our
democracy continues for generations to
come
who better to be on the other team than
some [ __ ] bonehead like Johnny mcatee
who couldn't work his way out of a wet
paper [ __ ] sack
who can't even pass a [ __ ] federal
background check all right
I think I think I would much rather have
people
on our side who get things passed like
infrastructure
physical infrastructure 1.2 trillion
dollars worth of physical infrastructure
that is
one of the biggest accomplishments not
just of Joe Biden's presidency
but infrastructure wise presidents
for the last 40 years haven't got the
kind of infrastructure that Joe Biden
got with the Democrats here
I think we're underestimating what kind
of win just that bill was now we're
going to get the big bird Bill some
people call it the build back better
bill but I'm calling it The Big Bird
bill and the reason why I call it the
Big Bird bill is because it really
triggers the right they're [ __ ] oh my
God this big bird porn thing they are
obsessed they are obsessed with
fictional characters they went on and on
you remember they went on and on and on
about Mr Potato Head they went on and on
and on about Dr Seuss and fictional
books children's books they always
they're always focused on these
children's characters
and they can't they can't seem to stop
obsessing about children's character
have you noticed this that the the Q
Anon cult JFK CRT Voodoo party the gqp
they always get these three letter
things that they do
the Q Anon voodoo
they're the ones who are obsessed with
children's characters
have you noticed that hmm
projection much
let me show you a tweet by a big bird
here
this is a fictional character it's a
puppet on Sesame Street
big bird is a six-year-old giant bird
who lives on Sesame Street
not not a real place it's it's not it's
a it's a it's just a [ __ ] set it's
not real Ted Cruz gqp Josh Hawley
because we're gonna get to that in a
minute because I think this Josh Hawley
porn thing in this big bird thing are
the same exact thing
same exact nonsense where they're
projecting
so big bird says I got my covid-19
vaccine today my wing is feeling a
little sore
but it'll give my body an extra
productive boost that keeps me and
others healthy take some advice Aaron
Rodgers you [ __ ]
Jesus Christ big bird is more of a
responsible citizen than someone who
throws a football for the Green Bay
Packers that has a huge platform that
makes 40 million dollars
and big birds the one that's being
attacked by these fascists
and by attack I mean Cancun Ted Cruz you
see here he says government propaganda
for your five-year-old what the [ __ ] is
he talking about
so apparently big bird has become deep a
deep stator now part of the government
what the [ __ ] are you talk set
whoosh
it is it is a TV show Ted Cruz it is a
[ __ ] character from Sesame Street
this is not deep State radical socialist
commies
you people have lost your goddamn Q Anon
Minds that you think that this is
government propaganda
there's a video out there uh Sesame
Street is released and a few others of
Big Bird back in 1972
doing a PSA on Sesame Street a sketch on
Sesame Street a PSA sketch encouraging
children to get the measles vaccine
because that's what we do in this
country when we have infectious disease
and we have a way a safe effective way
to stop it we do that thing to keep
others and their communities safe just
like the fictional six-year-old giant
bird said Ted Cruz you [ __ ] idiot
but this is all part of the same
bone-headed [ __ ]
this big bird obsession
this porn masculinity obsession
because Ted Cruz is threatened by Big
Bird
a fictional character
to encourage kids to get a vaccine
that is highly effective to keep them
their families or communities their
schools their friends their country safe
and a healthy it really it really is not
you we do not have to make arguments
about this thing anything past that
folks we are to the point to where we do
not have to argue with these people
anymore about freedom and liberty and I
want to keep my job and all this
nonsense we do not act that we do not
have to participate in that [ __ ]
because by participating in it you're
only you're only giving them more more
[ __ ] cause to talk about Freedom as
if they know what [ __ ] freedom is
here you have Ted Cruz wanting wanting
to censor a [ __ ] fictional bird who
is releasing a tweet that is a PSA
to put the hearts and minds of parents
at at ease that this vaccine is safe
because all the data proves that it's
safe we know the reason why Big Bird
tweeted this
and this is [ __ ] stupid I can't even
believe I have to say those words the
reason why Big Bird tweeted this big
bird is not a real the character it's
fictional it's fake
it's to make sure that kids know that
it's safe it's not gonna it's not gonna
hurt when you get the vaccine it's it's
for your health of you your friends your
community your teachers your school your
family your church
all those things it's for the health and
safety
for you to get the vaccine and for you
to protect you
and to pretend to pretend like that's
not what this is and to pretend like
we're gonna bring in freedom and liberty
and all this [ __ ] into this [ __ ]
conversation is [ __ ] dumb because
where were you the last [ __ ] hundred
years on vaccines where were you the
last hundred years where were you in
1972 Ted Cruz talking about how big bird
was some kind of [ __ ] radical
socialist comedy a deep stator who was
trying to indoctrinate children when he
was encouraging to get a measles vaccine
you [ __ ] you vaccinated [ __ ] Ted Cruz
and his entire family are vaccinated by
the way by the way Jimenez and Dyer
family are [ __ ] vaccinated hell his
new cat and snowflake are probably
vaccinated too
but the Josh Holly porn thing I don't
know if you've seen this because I'm
kind of rapping these two subjects in
the same thing because I really do think
it's the same q and on cult Maga Trump
humping white privilege fragility
argument here where Josh Holly does a
[ __ ] interview with axios where he's
talking about masculinity is the number
one the no this is what he says he says
it's the number one issue on America's
Minds hahaha
and I think I think what he wants
America to be concerned about is his
masculinity like he's like please please
think I'm masculine I I have a feeling
that social media thinks I'm I'm a simp
and a cuck yeah you are you [ __ ] when
you're projecting this stuff about porno
and video games Josh Holly goes on in
this interview and I don't have the clip
my Josh Holly goes on in the interview
to say that the only way that a man is a
man this is the only way the only way
that a man is a man is one if he's
married
and two if he has children
What What In the action is it just to
prove that you you I [ __ ] a woman and
the woman has children and I forced her
to have those children so I'm a man I'm
a manly man
is that the thing that you think that we
think when we see a man and his wife and
his children we think oh man he must oh
man look at him he had three kids can
you imagine she she had she had to hold
her nose and [ __ ] him three times at
least he must be he must be a man what
the [ __ ] is he talking about
you have to be a father you have to be a
husband
you have to be married and you have to
have children to be a man
he re he really he really is very
insecure not only about his own manhood
but his marriage and his parenting
skills apparently
that he's bringing this stuff up that
it's the number one thing that's
affecting America
is that we're canceling masculinity
we're canceling not not not not that
they tried to overthrow the constitution
in the United States
with a seditious attempt of a Cheeto
dust kangaroo coup forget about that
part of our democracy forget about how
they're trying to bang up all the
[ __ ] voting roles in the states so
they can steal the election the next
time for [ __ ] forget about how the
Republicans of the gqp are
gerrymandering every [ __ ] District
they can because they know if they don't
cheat they don't win
forget about that part forget about that
forget about that
forget about that don't worry about
don't don't don't worry about that
forget about all the people in these
Trump districts who are dying from covet
and getting sick from covenant being
hospitalized from covid because these
people who are vaccinated like Josh
Holly and takers are [ __ ] lying to
them Time After Time After Time After
Time with their fascist propaganda to
keep the pandemic going because let's be
frank I really don't think Ted Cruz
hates Big Bird he just wants to convince
the the [ __ ] Q Anon sheep out there
to hate Big Bird so they don't get
vaccinated because if they don't get
vaccinated they can continue the [ __ ]
the the covid chaos that's what they
want they want to continue the covet
chaos and all us vaccinated people out
there are not having this huge coveted
chaos it's just affecting our economy
it's affecting our country and it's
affecting our countrymen even though we
vehemently disagree with him on a lot of
things
politically socially
we still want them to be vaccinated we
still want them to be healthy we don't
want them to get other people sick
we don't want people to needlessly die
from an infectious disease where there's
a vaccine that can save you and your
countrymen that's patriotic you dumb
[ __ ]
as much as I hate the word patriotic
and I hate when we have to be Weaver
forced to be patriotic
when you're at the force Patriot
patriotism is is [ __ ] gross
but this idea that you wanting to people
to get vaccinated so that they their
communities and the rest of the country
is healthy so we can move past the
[ __ ] pandemic
and on to building a new economy without
it because we do we have to build back
part of our economy that's that's what
the big bird bill is
that's that's what the infrastructure
bill was
that's what the coveted relief bill was
to build back our economy post covid and
we're ready to do it all Americans are
ready besides you [ __ ] 15 of you
[ __ ] boneheads out there
that are listening to [ __ ] Josh
Hawley ramble on and on and on about how
you're not manly if you watch porn and
and play video games
he really is projecting there it's
almost like Josh Hawley
it's all it seems to me that he did he
he watches a lot of porn because he
doesn't know how to search PornHub
like no no guy out there no gal out
there really no purse no person out
there is is going like oh PornHub is Eve
I mean some may think PornHub is evil
let's face it porn's been around for a
long time it's been around for a long
time
and there's usually one purpose one
purpose for porn it's to masturbate
and it seems like Josh Hawley is having
a really tough time searching the things
that he that he's looking for and he has
to spend all day on PornHub
it really is frustrating him a lot that
he has to spend so much time on PornHub
because he even says in the interview he
says watching porn doing nothing most
people and and I know I know it's hard
to admit out there but I'll admit it in
front of the microphone
most people who search porn aren't
searching porn all day long
maybe a couple two three I mean some
people might do it 10 or 12 times a day
but it's only it's only for a little bit
amount of a time that they're doing this
we know why people watch porn we're all
human beings here it's kind of like well
why are you going to the grocery store
to get groceries
you stupid [ __ ]
but people don't spend all day in the
grocery store
they don't spend all day in the grocery
store wasting their whole day away in
the grocery store doing nothing
Josh Ollie you projecting piece of [ __ ]
we all we all know and I I actually
floated the idea on Twitter of what kind
of porn that he was searching for what
he was rummaging for that he's not
finding that keeps him on PornHub all
day long doing nothing
most people are doing a specific thing
when they're watching porn just after
Jeffrey tuben just ask him ask him next
time he's on CNN
he's as [ __ ] Christ and then the
video game thing are we over this yet
this [ __ ] I don't play video games
but this idea that video games makes you
some kind of lazy per it's really
[ __ ] stupid this is really [ __ ]
stupid that somehow it makes you some
kind of lazy person we went through the
80s and the 90s of people being quote
unquote addicted to television
we did that nonsense
can we stop with that it's it's a bad
thing for people to play video games can
we stop that nonsense that's all
[ __ ] that's all [ __ ] it's
something they like to do it's something
they want to do it's entertaining I it
doesn't entertain me I don't play video
games but what the [ __ ] is the big deal
to play video games it it actually
connects people in this Society
sometimes yeah and and for good and for
bad I'm not saying it's all good I'm
just saying to [ __ ] pin it up like
video games is some kind of demon just
because it's a video game get the [ __ ]
out of here
we need to check ourselves this is
ridiculous
so
keep Georgia on your mind keep an eye on
that story that's going to be a hot
story in the months to come with that
grand jury convening we'll see what kind
of indictments coming out of that uh
[ __ ] Karen Rogers I mean Aaron Rodgers I
I don't really watch football I don't
have cable anymore so I wouldn't watch
the Packers uh now even if I had to even
if I could uh and we'll see what happens
to Paul gozar I I'm sure I'm sure we're
gonna eventually work our way to the
subpoena City with these subpoenas where
we're going to see these members of
Congress get subpoenaed and we better
hear something from doj soon Merrick
Garland or the American people are gonna
get really [ __ ] impatient with you
you really need to get on the ball here
and communicate with us why why Steve
Bannon hasn't been indicted on criminal
charges of contempt yet rather You're
convening a grand jury or waiting on
something you need to communicate you
need to be a little transparent I know
you don't say anything about ongoing
investigations but you did with Hillary
Clinton you did with the [ __ ] email
lady let's get to it
let's get to it
oh yeah and let's cheer on Big Bird if
you guys don't know this
um there was a Twitter account that
popped up and there's several of them
that have popped up Sesame Street
accounts their parity accounts a big
bird for Senate go follow
go follow big birds Senate campaign uh
it may get interesting with him and Ted
Cruz you know Ted Cruz thinking that big
bird is is real that he's not a uh a
puppet from Sesame Street all right
that's the [ __ ] list the shitlist
thanks for joining me here on the
podcast today I really do appreciate it
and again uh if you guys if you guys
would go go uh go see us uh at the merch
store uh use the word podcast you get 10
off all merch just go to the
tonymichaels.com there's the hat store
and the merch store go check that out we
have some new [ __ ] em hats and there's
there's some new colors some new designs
so go check out the [ __ ] em hats now I'm
I'm gonna order some samples so I can
wear them so you guys can see what those
new hats those new hat designs look like
but go to the hat store at the
tonymichaels.com use the promo code
podcast and get 10 off your purchase
go see that also go follow us on Twitch
again we're going to have those
streaming um there's the live streams
every day where we surf Twitter the [ __ ]
list Roundup as we call it where we're
rounding up the [ __ ] list for the weekly
show here on the podcast so go download
the Twitch app follow us on Twitch uh
watch that stream now you don't have to
watch it live you can want re-watch it
on Twitch or sometimes if I think
YouTube won't take it down I go post it
on YouTube if I say things
um in a certain way on Twitch then I may
be able to get away with that I won't be
able to get away with on YouTube
sometimes I don't go post it but they
always stay on Twitch for a while so go
go download the Twitch app you can
re-watch those episodes uh every day and
we're gonna start doing it at noon noon
Eastern excuse me noon Eastern 11th
Central every day we're gonna stream for
an hour like we have been or try to
stream for an hour and then we'll do the
special streams too so again Go download
the Twitch app that's the easiest way to
watch watch us on Twitch or you can
watch the stream on Twitter you can do
that too we stream that uh the shitless
Roundup on Twitter as well but go to
your favorite uh uh directory your
podcast directory whether it be apple
Spotify and give us a review and
remember I'm hoping Friday hoping our
schedules collide with this special
guest so that we can record that special
guest episode I will keep you up to date
with that news on Twitter
uh so so be paying attention to that and
until next time [ __ ] em you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em